the long-awaited 16 inch MacBook Pro is
finally here into our surprise the base
model is still 2400 dollars and from the
looks of it you're truly getting a lot
for your money
with upgraded speakers microphones
thinner bezels better battery life new 7
nanometre AMD navi graphics and finally
a reliable scissor switch keyboard with
the physical Escape key so in this video
we're gonna go over some mistakes you
should avoid when ordering your new 16
inch macbook pro along with which 2018
macbook you should buy based on your
specific needs
along with which upgrades are worth it
for mistake number one don't start with
a twenty eight hundred dollar model
thinking that it's a better deal
compared to starting with the $2,400
base model we actually chose identical
specs while starting with both and it
came out to the exact same price so you
can save quite a bit of cash by starting
with the base model and skipping out on
the upgrades that you don't need there's
actually only one way that choosing the
$2,800 model right away can save you
some cash and that leads us into mistake
number two if you want the eight core a
nine processor choose the $2,800 model
and stick with the 2.3 gigahertz eight
core CPU if you start with a twenty four
hundred dollar model it costs three
hundred dollars to upgrade to the more
expensive 2.4 gigahertz eight core
processor which I honestly don't think
will give you enough of a performance
boost to make it worth a price this way
that extra two hundred dollars you saved
goes towards the storage and graphics
upgrade which I think are well worth it
for mistake number three do not buy
aspect out 13-inch MacBook Pro the 16
inch pro already comes with 16 gigs of
RAM a 6 core i7 processor and 512 gigs
of SSD storage at the base $2,400 price
if you choose a 13-inch MacBook Pro and
upgrade to the same specs you're
actually spending $2,500 while getting a
slower 4 core CPU and missing out on all
the 16 inch MacBook Pros new features
that I mentioned at the beginning of
this video so the new 16 inch MacBook
Pro gives you absolutely incredible bang
for your buck for the fourth mistake
don't upgrade the graphics if you're a
photo editor we've tested it many times
in the past and graphics did absolutely
nothing for photo editing now
my room has recently been updated with
graphics acceleration but the base
graphics is good enough to take
advantage of that upgrading to better
graphics won't improve speeds enough to
make the upgrade worth it so start with
the base $2,400 model and leave it at
the base graphics to get the best value
for photo editing the fifth mistake is
buying too little or too much RAM now
that you can get up to 64 gigabytes of
RAM it may be tempting to max it out but
most people actually don't need that
much RAM the people who can make use of
it already know they need it so if
you're not quite sure then trust me you
don't need 64 gigs of RAM now photo
editor should absolutely upgrade to 32
gigs of ram before upgrading the cpu
because in our testing 16 gigs of ram
actually limited performance in
lightroom but for a lot of other people
you may actually be perfectly fine with
just 16 gigs of ram for mistake number 6
if you're a video editor or anyone who
renders graphics absolutely upgrade to
the Radeon Pro 5500 M with 8 gigabytes
of memory before you upgrade anything
else more and more applications are
getting more dependent on graphics like
Final Cut Pro 10 which has recently been
updated with a new metal graphics engine
so it uses even less processing
performance than before and it's much
more reliant on graphics however if
you're editing high-end raw footage
that's where the processor really comes
into play so make sure you're getting
the eight core CPU for Rock codecs
what's really great about the 16 inch
macbook pro is that the best graphics is
available with the base $2,400 model
compared to the old 15-inch MacBook Pro
or you had to start with the more
expensive $2,800 model to even gain
access to the best Vega 20 graphics
option saving video editors a massive
550 dollars to get the best graphics and
finally for mistake number seven don't
overspend on storage which can be the
most expensive upgrade out of all of
them this year Apple has given us 512
gigs of storage at the base $2,400 price
which used to have to pay an extra $200
for so it's such a great value and with
the 15-inch MacBook Pro you used to have
to pay $400 to upgrade from 512 gigs of
storage to one terabyte
and now it's only $200 so I'd say that
it's definitely worth a price the
craziest thing is that you can upgrade
from 512 gigs of storage to 8 terabytes
for $2,400 whereas it used to cost
$2,800 to go from 512 gigs to only 4
terabytes of storage and now 4 terabytes
is only $1,200 which is a massive
savings compared to before but to be
completely honest a lot of people should
be totally fine with just one terabyte
of storage so only upgrades are more
than that if you absolutely know that
you need it so with all those purchasing
mistakes out of the way let's get into
our 2019 macbook buyers guide where we
recommend a macbook for each specific
use case if you're a user who does
simple stuff like web browsing school or
business work or using web-based apps we
recommend just going for the base 2019
MacBook Air which is now on sale on
Amazon for only $1000 now if you do a
little bit of photo or video editing
maybe some rendering programming or
producing any kind of content you'll
definitely see the benefits of the
MacBook Pro so you should go with the
base 2019 13-inch MacBook Pro which is
also on sale for only 1150 on Amazon and
maybe upgrade the storage or RAM if you
have some extra room in your budget now
if you're doing those tasks almost
everyday and you take it very seriously
you should actually skip the $1,800
13-inch MacBook Pro and go straight for
the base $2,400 16 inch MacBook Pro
since it's such an amazing value with
all of its upgrades and the dedicated
graphics card which the 13-inch doesn't
get at all now if you're a regular Video
Editor start with the $2,400 model and
simply upgrade to the best graphics for
a total of $2,600
if you're a high-end Video Editor start
with the $2,800 model then upgrade to 32
gigabytes of RAM and the best graphics
for a total of $3,300 if you're a
regular photo editor start with the
$2,400 model and simply upgrade to 32
gigabytes of RAM for a total of $2,800
the six core CPU will actually be fine
for you now for high-end photo editors
start with the $2,400 model then upgrade
to the best 2.4 gigahertz processor and
upgrade to 32 gigabytes of RAM for a
total of 30
one hundred dollars now if you really
want to upgrade graphics for the best
Lightroom graphics acceleration you can
but make sure it's the last thing you
upgrade
I chose 32 gigs of RAM because I
actually think 64 gigabytes of RAM is
overkill for photo editing unless you're
working with tons of layers and you know
32 gigs isn't enough I personally feel
like 64 gigs of ram is more for people
who are running virtual machines and
stuff like that and of course you choose
the amount of storage you want for each
of these Mac books because it's totally
reliant on how much do you think you
need we've already ordered two of the
sixteen inch MacBook Pros which we
should receive in two days so if you're
not already subscribed click that circle
above to see your upcoming comparison
videos if this video helped you out make
sure it's at that like button below
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]